order before I look to the father of the
house and then other colleagues I want
to say the following well they're the
government's intention to hope this
debate at this inordinately late stage
has been widely leaked to the media in
advance
I felt it only appropriate to hear what
is proposed before advising the house
holding the debate after no fewer than
164 colleagues have taken the trouble to
contribute will be thought by many
members of this house to be deeply
discourteous indeed in the hours since
news of this intention emerged many
colleagues from across the house have
registered that view to me in the most
forceful terms having taken the best
procedural advice colleagues should be
informed that there are two ways of
doing this the first and in democratic
terms the infinitely preferable way is
for a minister to move at the outset of
the debate that the debate be adjourned
this will give the house the opportunity
to express its view in a vote whether or
not it wishes the debate to be brought
to a premature and inconclusive end I
can reassure ministers that I would be
happy to accept such a motion so that
the house can decide
the alternative is for the government
unilaterally to decline to move today's
business which means that the house is
not only deprived of its opportunity to
vote upon the substance of the debate
tomorrow but also that it is given no
chance to express its view today on
whether the debate should or should not
be allowed to continue I politely
suggest that in any courteous respectful
and mature environment allowing the
house to have a say each say on this
matter would be the right and dare I say
the obvious course to take let us see if
those who have assured this house and
the public over and over and over again
that this supremely important vote is
going to take place tomorrow without
fail wish to rise to the occasion